alright movie reveal yeah this was
phantasm - we brought you phantasm one
and we said yeah you know we said that
was a pretty good movie for being such a
little budget flick and really fantastic
two tops it I think it tops it yeah this
is one of the few times when the sequel
is actually better than the original
yeah don't you agree I do but I think
the the horror community seems a little
divided on I don't care what they're
saying I'm saying I'm just saying look
look at them look at the difference in
the sets yeah look at the difference I'm
gonna kind of get into that a little bit
to it what like why why people thought
that oh so the thing about phantasm one
was that you know like we said in our
review of it it's very low-budget you
know they filmed it for you know
phantasm 1 was almost like a fan film
done for life yeah you may be that in
when you're watching it it is
communicating a lot of you know care you
know I mean they didn't have a lot of
money but they cared about what they
were doing and they you could tell this
kind of made by group friends really
yeah yeah and you know they're telling
you a story and they're taking you on a
journey I liked it I thought it was good
now the thing about phantasm 2 is that
they approached Universal Studios
approached Don Coscarelli and wanted to
do a sequel so he actually got three
million dollars which you know
comparatively that's a lot of money to
do a horror sequel because there was a
lot of horror sequels from production in
the mid to late 80s and they thought we
know we're gonna jump on the cash cow
because phantasm was a big cult hit so
they gave him three million dollars
which he was happy about and they were
able to hire you know Greg Nicotero and
his can be studios to do the effects and
the effects to look very good yeah that
the rules but one of the things that
horror fans were kind of pissed off
about is that the studio did not want
the kid who played Mike in the first
movie to be in the second movie I can
understand whether because he was not a
working actor like Simon in that movie
and he hadn't really been any movies in
the I believe it was nine years yeah you
know between the two movies so they said
well we want somebody that's you know
Screen Actors Guild somebody's like a
working actor right and so I can
understand
yes the original my big pissed off about
that is that the actor that they did use
was good
yeah they got James Lacroix and he was
actually pretty good in it um the the
original actor did come back for three
and four yes I haven't seen and again a
lot there's a lot of divisive kind of
stuff on there some people are like well
three is like super campy but it's super
fun right the fourth one which i think
is called phantasm oblivion rut is
supposedly it's like some people's
favorite one right but I understanding
that those were like directed DVD
releases they were which a lot of times
me means terrible but you know what
recently directed DVD if you're buying
it from the right person is quite good
yeah I don't really think that it has
the same stigma that he does to have
like stuff thick enough I mean [ __ ] look
at the awesome stuff that goes right to
DVD rates and Netflix rather yeah you
know some of that stuff some of the new
Stallone stuff pretty much very limited
theatrical release it's meant to make
its money DVD like Expendables and I
think bullet to the head those are
awesome yeah but they're targeted right
to Stallone's audience yeah yeah it's
good a so they never would have existed
without that ability to go direct to DVD
you know I probably pay-per-view and
stuff like that but that's awesome so I
kind of like that new element into show
business
you know I mean where you never worried
about theatrical releases too much you
know well yeah the you know the the
limit of entry is like much lower yeah
it's easier for people to get a movie
made because you don't have to worry
necessarily about it playing in theaters
I mean if you can get his target rights
as a fans
yeah or whatever I mean even even a guy
like Segal who makes terrible movies can
target to his friends I've seen those
things I can't understand anybody
watching this I get they're not even fun
to watch that's just like he had a DVD
that had like seven or eight movies on
it for two dollars yeah I saw that you
know you would probably feel like you
overpaid yeah yeah so phantasm 2 was
actually the last theatrical release of
the phantasm franchise now I think I
mentioned this on the first one but I
saw phantasm two in the theater
in 1988 I don't was I even old enough I
don't even remember but I saw it and I
specifically remember seeing in theatre
and I remember there being like big
layouts about it in Fang gory and stuff
with all the cool special effects like
them so man like the yellow melting and
all that stuff at the end and so I had
actually seen part two before I saw part
one like I said there are two it didn't
do well at the box office I believe some
other big movie came out around the same
time it had been such a long time since
the first movie in the first movie it
was kind of a cult horror movie so I
think it didn't really have a lot of
broad mainstream appeal right although
they did have on the blu-ray they have
that great that great documentary about
it where they show like the premiere and
they had to Tom it was there the hearse
and yeah the whole big thing yeah and it
was like I get like all the hardcore
fans shared ups all the horror nerds are
out there with their shirts and
everything it like it really really
didn't do very well at all and the thing
is that the first one was very surreal
and very like a dream and so yeah you
weren't really sure what the rules were
things would happen and this is kind of
surreal but I think there was some
studio meddling where they said we don't
really want any dream sequences we want
a more straightforward story right yeah
so I think people were kind of mad about
that because I think what people liked
about the original phantasm once it was
just like a fever dream like they make
sense and it didn't even meet you it was
just creepy and that was their silver
balls come back there's three of them
now one of them is exit kind of gold
they have different things now so they
kind of upped the game
yeah everything in this is more there's
like more of them you know it's not
jobless look better yeah I always show
their face yeah their little feet and
their little feet yes and they kind of
explain a little bit more about the
mythology not a lot it's not like a road
picture honestly yeah now the
interesting thing is that you don't
really have to have seen the first movie
to see the cuz I saw this one first and
I wasn't super confused or anything
because like I said it's one of those
ones that it kind of has surrealistic
elements you just have to roll with it
anyway but you know there's not a lot
that's that she's not explained that was
not explained the first one so it's you
know it's fine this picture here is more
like a convinced
horror movie yes maybe it's because
there was more money behind it unless
the studio's gonna try to keep things
grounded they're like no that's a money
that's don't do that okay no do more of
this the crowd will like that yeah
they're professionals they know yeah I'm
gonna tell you know maybe you know I
think it was better than part one even
though I enjoyed part one I think part
one really set the stage for this movie
some people would say hey man part one's
the original I understand that too you
know anybody yeah I don't have the
nostalgia for it because I've only seen
them recently
yeah and from my point of view I really
appreciated part one I thought that was
an awesome little budget flick this is
more has a bigger budget it feels like
it has a bigger budget it is a little
more conventional second I can see this
structure as you are I just lecturing
the way it sounds a little more
convinced it's not dream lightning rush
and some of the stuff that was happening
the first one I think was you know
talent not money but just talent and I'm
trying to get around the oh yeah get the
tasks done you know as cheaply as
possible and sometimes that'll give you
a certain feel that get puts on like a
creepy heir to the movie ya know like
what's what did they call it a
atmosphere the actors a little creepy
because it's not conventional it's like
a bunch of crime scene photos or
something like that yeah you know and
that's kind of like what the first ones
like this was more like a regular
Hollywood horror movie but it's still
pretty weird though yeah it's weird I
mean it's not really like anything else
that came out it still has a realistic
yet say oh and they took the weirdness
of a phantasm one and they kind of made
it a little bit more palatable and a
little bit more presentable for the big
screen
yeah I think it's that be aware then I
don't really think I mean like I said I
think I have even more nostalgia for
this one that I dented the first one
because I saw this one first I saw it in
the theater I had all the Fangoria stuff
I had like posters that I had pulled out
of Fangoria they were on my wall of the
Taliban and stuff and also when it came
out on cable after I taped it on VHS for
all you kids that had that you know tape
actual yes and I had so I had to BHS
tape of it taped off cable and I watched
it over and over and it's funny because
I haven't seen it for years
years and years yeah and when we got it
on blu-ray and weari watched it and I
was like I was amazed at how much it
just all came back on camera because I
had forgotten a lot of this stuff like
in the ensuing years because I haven't
seen it for probably 20 years the
blu-ray transfer that I have of this it
looks fantastic
it's really nice and the effects look
yeah right the music is good too
soundtracks good it's got a lot of
extras you know behind the scenes stuff
interviews documentaries yeah it's a
good buy I think that was shout factory
when it might have been yes bring back
something I've averaged out better
Stephanie with someone like that
yeah it was I think it's the only
blu-ray offering up there on you eBay
right about now yeah it was just I
didn't really see too many different
choices for part two I'm gonna go check
out part 3 to see you yeah I don't think
there's a blu-ray release for I think
it's only I want to see the other
because you know we've had people tell
us that the other two are good too and
you know I like I like the whole concept
of the series so I really would like to
see and kind of judge for myself but
they probably go back to the roots and
that that were there in phantasm one
well they go to the entire original cast
yeah so you know the first kit that
guide the kid that played Mike in the
first movie comes back in the third and
the fourth I'm not sure about the fifth
Ravager I don't have that even come out
yet yeah it's out yeah okay so and some
people were saying that that was like
the best one yeah so yeah that's right
so there's five yeah but yeah so so this
one I want to say like there's a lot of
really cool extra stuff on the blu-ray
also there was a you know there's a
whole body called a whole documentary
called I think it's called the ball is
back because that's that was the poster
tagline that's just kind of about the
making evidence about 48 minutes and
then there's a thing about Greg Nicotero
who's so pretty young in 1988 talking
about doing all the special effects work
I mean this is for sure gory ER than the
person way gory or it's been a goofy
yeah and there is difference we yank
about it the phantasm one was creepy
because it had kind of cheap elements to
it the special effects were low-budget
but they were kind of effective even
though you could tell they were fake
yeah they were effective
because they were cheap and also in a
way kind of looked creepy yeah it kind
of gave you a different emotional
response I think that's why some of the
cheap movies from the seventies are so
kind of eerie because they almost look
like a home movie yeah really happy yeah
Chris felt the whole movie and a snuffly
yeah I mean I had that feel to it this
one doesn't have that feel the special
effects they're all practical effects
there they're good practical effects for
my pony yeah they stood up very well
yeah you know I like practical effects
there's some about it you know I mean
even though well everything is actually
there yeah to me they're not really
convincing I know the trick that they
did but I like that better than the CG I
particularly like and it's kind of such
a little thing yeah but I kind of like
the one scene where the priest gets his
ear to ear sliced off by the ball yeah
and they showed how they did it yeah and
I was like yeah it was like such a
simple little thing so simple but you
wouldn't really think of it but they
thought of it and it looked great I
thought yeah but yeah so but like I said
it looks like this when everything is
ramped up there's Maria more Gore
there's it's a little bit more
believable the gore because the mic for
it's a little immediate II you know it
looks better one of the coolest things
about this and this was this movie right
they blew up that actual house yeah so
that wasn't there was no CGI was it a
trick it wasn't a miniature house a lot
of house it was abandoned
yeah for some stupid call that all
that's funny they were gonna build it
they were moving a freeway yeah so all
those houses were yeah they were
worthless and something most of the
people were buying them and they're
having trucks coming to pick them up and
move them somewhere else right they just
bought it for like a hundred bucks and
blew it up on site they make it blow it
up yeah and the best thing about it is
that well they can only blow it up once
obviously yeah so they had to have like
three things going on at the same time
you had to have yeah Mike and and the
chick like running over here you have
Reggie over here and you had that the
tall man yeah coming away from the
explosion so they had to film like three
different times simultaneous
simultaneously as the house
and the best thing about this is the
tall man he's just like walking away
from the explosion like it ain't no
thing yeah it's like all cool and jet
like yep house is blowing up right and
he totally did that yeah angus scrimm is
such a trooper yeah he's passed away now
sadly yeah yeah and you was you miss
excuse Talent all the guy even back in
these days yeah and really he he's come
there's cool about him because he really
really seemed to like that character
yeah he like they seemed to have a good
time yeah playing it like he wouldn't he
was out at the when they showed him at
the UM at the opening and everything he
was all like hamming up the role and
everything and they showed him at
different horror cons and stuff so he
really seemed like he was into that role
and I thought that was pretty cool so
this one like I said the cool thing
about this don coscarelli I mean you
know when he wrote the original phantasm
he is gone a record is saying why had
never planned to make a sequel I mean I
thought the end of phantasm was pretty
definitive yeah so you know nine years
later when they come and go hey am I
going to do a sequel to that he said no
I had no idea what to do and then
finally he said hey you know why don't I
just make it start exactly where the
first one ended yeah
which it kind of does but then it kind
of jumps forward in time obviously
because they had to have a older actor
so when James libero comes as Mike that
he was a kid in the first one he's
evidently been at a mental hospital
because he told people about all the
tall men and the little dwarves and
everything like that everyone thought he
was crazy so he's been in a mental
hospital for like seven years or
something like that and then he gets out
and he decides what he actually fakes
sanity well he's saying obviously
mistake it's crazy but he fakes he's
like yeah that's that stuff that was all
totally [ __ ] yeah let me out so they
let him out and then he goes and hooks
up with Reggie again and they go on like
on a road trip because I guess they
don't really say this outright they were
looking for the tow man but I guess the
tall man what he does is he goes from
small towns and pretty much dwarf eyes
all of the dead people in the town and
then all the towns are abandoned yeah
and then he moves on to the next one
because and that's another like creepy
aspect I don't believe it like to ask
his Amba film yeah guys here's Mike and
Reggie in the Hemi Cuda and they're
going from these little towns in the
Pacific Northwest yeah they go to this
town that's just like all abandoned and
boarded up and all the cemeteries are
all empty like they're all the graves
are open and all this other kind of
stuff it's really cool oh and they
shovels and by the way they roll the
Hemi Cuda in this one it's not the exact
same car first one was beautiful all
right they bought a Hemi Cuda and rolled
it even back in the day so when they
when people were like wait a minute home
do you want to destroy these there
aren't many of these left
yeah they rolled it I know and you got
very upset even at 88 those were hard to
find
and I was actually reading a review of
this on the a/v Club and a couple like
most of people on there that were
commenting we're like oh I love this
movie so much and I said somebody did
comment it's like oh my god I can't
believe it
the car probably survived the role you
could problem I hope so only me know it
blew up set it on fire
that was the cooter that was burning
yeah it's like they can't afford it
Alexis yeah sometimes you can go to the
junkyard and another mater will come and
go yeah I could fix that yeah yeah well
not it's just like a burn house
so another thing they do in this one
like I said other than making a room if
they introduce a couple more characters
one of them is the blonde girl at the
beginning and she is introduced
I guess she lives in a town where the
tall man is is now and the tow man is in
the process of draining this town and
almost everybody's gone and her grandma
dies and stuff like that but she has a
psychic link with Mike so they've been
like communicating in their dreams and
he somehow knows that she's a real
person and so they're kind of looking
for her as well they don't really
explain why she has a psychic link with
him or you know how he knows that she's
a real person or where she's at or
anything like that but it doesn't really
matter and then the other character they
introduced is alchemy yeah and she's
this hitchhiker that they picked up on
the road now creepily before this in
one of the abandoned towns Mike has seen
a dead body on a slab in a morgue that
looks like her but then like when he
looks back it's not there so he's like I
want must have just been seeing things
but then they pick her up later on right
one of the best things and this was
actually I don't know why I remembered
this scene the most of all weapons but
where alchemy and Reggie are having sex
in the cabin or whatever and she keeps
smacking his bald head yeah yeah oh god
Reggie I love your head so he's beating
him up pretty bad and that actress wife
was on the other side of the wall during
that during that scene yeah he's in his
forties and she's like 18 or 19 I know I
thought that was the one yeah they won
one thing I do like about part two is
they introduced this evidently ongoing
concept of Reggie being like a babe
magnet
yeah he's basically bald with a bullet
yeah which I could see though because in
this one Reggie kind of channels his
inner Rambo yeah he beat ice cream man
yeah yeah he becomes very heroic in this
like there it there is character
development in this movie yeah you will
you will enjoy it yeah it's pretty cool
yeah all kind of crazy weapons and uh
yeah I can kind of see an Evil Dead
influence in the soul oh yeah definitely
oh is that meant some stuff from the
Evil Dead I was just glad to finally get
to see the phantasm property yeah
because I remember it from elementary
school and I wasn't able to see it at
that time and then I'm kind of forgotten
all about it recently just doing this
show I was able to find it you know what
I never got to see phantasm yeah so now
I get to see a horror franchise from the
past that I never got to see you know
that's pretty cool I always like when
that happened right this is I like when
people recommend like movies from the
70s and 80s haven't heard of yeah we're
all people you know we think we know it
all we think we've seen all these movies
but then we remember you know what I
know
I've seen a good portion of them but
there there aren't some that fall
through the cracks yeah this one fell
through the cracks in the Edit yes it
was this good or I would have watched it
a long time ago this is up there for me
as a franchise this kind of property
equal dad maybe yeah yeah like I said
this is less wacky and more surreal I
guess yeah so far I've lived in yellow
and interestingly I was gonna say when
you said it was influenced by Evil Dead
there is a little scene in this where
one of the cemetery guys or workers he
takes somebody out of the Crematory oven
and smushes their bones up and
everything and then he's pouring the
cremains in the plastic bag and the
little label on the plastic bag says sam
raimi on it
I wonder if sam raimi saw that it was
like oh yeah yeah they refer to each
other's movies all the time but you guys
haven't seen phantasm to go ahead to see
it you love it yeah I actually like it a
little bit better than the original less
surreal it's more like a real movie but
it's still pretty surreal comparatively
I'm looking forward to by the other ones
I'm not by a ball yeah I did will join
for some other ones that we'll see how
well do reviews on like I said I've
heard mixed reviews some people love
them some people hate them so you know I
like che movies too I mean you can give
me a shitty movie and if it is longer so
shitty in a particular way as long as
I'm in as long as as long as I'm either
laughing at it or with it or you know
enjoy right then I can I can put on
Steven Seagal and I can take it there I
mean yeah depending you know I can start
laughing
well actually that last one that I put
off yeah I found you know I found a
bootleg copy yeah for my stepdads stuff
that I inherited and I put it in there
and it was great until until I see Steve
Seagal he had the worst fake southern
accent of all times and he's just trying
to talk tough and talk shop like he's a
Special Operations soldiers really and
then it's a total fake he's a total fake
I just can't stand it with ease he's a
big dude all right
he can't grasp it has nothing doing
martial arts although you know they say
he's it now you might eat you he's a
shot he's a shot
- master they say he can rub breast
cancer right out of it - no he can't all
through Hollywood just try sis gotta be
the lamest line he's notorious for
trying to help women with breast cancer
at even that's right up there with the
whole telling women you're a
gynecologist so yeah exactly yeah let me
check make sure things okay down yeah
like how like I don't understand how you
would even you would have to be either
really really stupid or really arrogant
so that was gonna work it's like really
99.99% of women on earth will just look
at you yes we gotta get back to back on
topic yeah what's his name he's gonna
know he's gonna waddle over to this
house and he uses to paint that hair on
I got a picture before doctor just
Krylon when he was when he was in his
30s he actually had a receding hairline
now he's got a full-on Eddie Munster
widow's peak and it's razor sharp
yeah you could cut glass with that has a
little template that he uses to your
honor you know how girls have those
little templates for eyebrows draw
eyebrows on it's like a little plastic
kind of thing that yeah he probably has
that just like it's like a triangle just
risen and then you spray your clip cry
later on your head and kind of touch it
up yeah we gotta go phantasm - tell us
if you like - better than the first one
or if you like it better than the first
one I actually like it a little bit
better than the first I think
but I can understand if you don't the
mausoleum looks so much better it does
sets yeah I mean the first one that
mausoleum set did look cool but you
could tell that was comarca wallpaper
yeah and it's the same pattern over and
over and over yeah in a way that kind of
made it cool it made it look like a
dream a really bad dream of a mausoleum
like you weren't looking at a real model
and that was something there's a
mausoleum from an image in your head to
each your apt oh yeah which is a
nightmarish quality yeah because the
stuff didn't really look really really
real yeah but it looked like some [ __ ]
you come up with like in is right like
when you have yeah whenever I have a
nightmare sometimes it's taking place an
old run-down 70s houses with really worn
out cheap shag carpeting everywhere it's
sad it's furniture and it doesn't and it
looks so 70s and rundown doesn't really
look real it looks like something you
just invent it looks like something on
this movie yeah yeah oh yeah so yeah
phantasm to use a lot slicker the gore
is still very good I think the gore
holds up pretty well actually the effort
for practical effects of the time you
know maybe a t-shirt and like I said it
was Greg Nicotero who's kind of like you
know he's the gold standard pretty much
right as far as that goes so you know
there's a forward to seeing part yeah
I'm forward to seeing part three yeah
and at four or five I'll watch them all
yeah and we will do reviews of those
awesome so if you remember if you liked
the show remember to Like share
subscribe and share with all your
friends also if you'd like to
financially support the show we have a
patreon page at patreon.com slash their
10th up or you can go to our blog at 13
o'clock podcast WordPress comm and there
is a link in the sidebar to a PayPal
account if you'd like to give a one-time
donation also remember to check out our
regular episodes which come out every
Tuesday and our movie reviews which come
out every Friday and until next time bye